GOOD AFTERNOON OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE FOR MONDAY APRIL
EIGHTH TWENTY NINETEEN IS
HEREBY CALL TO ORDER -- PLEASE
BE ADVISED OF THE AUDIO AND
VIDEO RECORDINGS DAYS BECAUSE
IT IS BEING MADE THIS ALSO
BE TELEVISED -- MEN OF SECTOR
PLEASE CALL COOLEY HERE
CUNNINGHAM HERE CARILLO FLORA
GRAYSON I'M HONORED UP HERE
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS BRITISH WORKS HERE WE
HAVE A QUORUM AND WE HAVE A
CONSENT AGENDA IS OUR MOTION
ON THE CONSENT AGENDA -- BY
MISS WORK SECOND AYE MR MATHIS
-- MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM AYE CUNNINGHAM HIGH
CARILLO FLORA FLORA AYE GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE KAMLAGER-DOVE HI
KAMLAGER-DOVE I AM MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS FOUND THE SITE QUIRK
SILVA AYE QUIRK SILVA AYE
RAMOS FROM MOST I READ THIS
REGIS I WORKS WORKS RIGHT THE
MOST AS PASSED -- THIS RULES
PRESSURES THANK YOU VERY MUCH